are the rates going to drop where are
they going to go well the FED forecast
and there's a whole bunch of these
acronyms that you hear all the time if
you read The Wall Street Journal
you'll see them all the time and you can
go to all sorts of news stories you'll
be reading something all of a sudden
there's a document and one of the things
is there is sofr secured overnight
financing rate data all that means is
what are the averages looking like what
is the weather forecast for interest
rates and there's two to look at one is
the market
does what's called betting on Futures so
the market you can tell what the market
thinks is going to happen to interest
rates and then you have a Fed forecast